in the middle of the harsh desert in  peru surrounded by miles of rolling sand  dunes there's a small oasis that's far  from a mirage  the town of wakachina has a population  of about 100 people and is one of the  few remaining natural oases in north and  south america  it's a popular tourist destination  hosting tens of thousands of tourists  each year  in its heyday the village flourished as  an elite resort getaway for the wealthy  who once flocked to the waters of the  lagoon because it was thought to have  medicinal  properties the resort became so popular  it is even featured on peru's official  currency  legend holds that the lagoon was created  when a beautiful native princess was  apprehended at her bath by a young  hunter she fled leaving the pool of  water she had been bathing in to become  the lagoon and the woman herself is  rumored to still live in the oasis as a  mermaid  you